-Give it up for the fantastic
8G Band right over there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we're also so happy to have
our friend Fred Armisen
here with us this week.
Give it up for Fred,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was Fred's birthday
this weekend, and we were all on
a text chain with Maya and Amy,
our friends.
That was so nice.
Maya Rudolph, Amy Poehler.
-So nice, so nice.
I miss them.
-I miss them, too.
-You know, it's a bummer.
They wanted to come on
to promote the new season
of "Baking It,"
but they could only be guests
via Zoom so it didn't work out.
-You didn't want
to have them on Zoom?
-No, I just feel like once
you have some guess
via Zoom,
everyone wants to do it.
You know, so it's just like a
slippery slope.
-Okay, I can see that then.
That makes total sense.
-Yeah, I love baking.
Thanks for supporting me
on that.
Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It doesn't make sense.
-What's wrong with you?
-What are you guys doing?
-Hi.
But what are you doing here?
-Well, we're doing this
interview via Zoom
the way we told you
we were going to do it.
-Yeah, but -- but I said no.
-Yeah, it's not up to you, Seth.
It's up to the audience.
-Oh, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys want us
to do it via Zoom?
Yeah, that's what I thought.
That's what I thought.
-Guys, it's great to see you,
but it's just less fun via Zoom.
-Seth, you're less fun via Zoom.
Maya and I are fun
no matter what.
-Plus, Zoom is great
for interviews
because you can pretend
the connection is bad...
-Yeah.
-...when you get asked
a tough question.
Go ahead, ask us a tough
question.
Just ask me anything.
-Yeah, we know you usually do
softballs, but I don't know.
Try us a tough question
for once.
-Yes, ask us a tough one.
-Yeah, do like
a Jake Tapper tough one.
-Alright, fine, fine.
You want a tough question?
Who do you guys think
should take over
"SNL" after Lorne leaves?
-That's a great ques--
I think...
if...
[ Laughter ]
five...
forever.
-See?
See how fun that was?
-Was it a baby, Amy?
Were you saying a baby?
-A baby's gonna take over
after Lorne.
-I'm just worried.
I love to see you guys again.
I'm just worried that I say it's
okay to have one guest on Zoom
then everyone's going to want
to be on Zoom.
-No.
-Okay.
Would you have Clooney
and Roberts via Zoom?
-Yeah.
George and Julia?
-Yeah, if they wanted to come on
Zoom, would you say yes?
-Would you?
-I mean, I guess so.
-Yeah, well, good news, dude,
because we're the new Clooney
and Roberts.
-Pretty woman right here.
-Danny Ocean right here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wait, Amy, why are you
Danny Ocean?
-Oh, I'm Danny Ocean.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, I'm Danny Ocean.
You know why?
-Why
-Seth, where's your wallet?
-Check my wallet?
-Yeah.
-It's in my pocket.
Wait.
-Is it?
-Oh, God. Oh no.
[ Laughter ]
Zoom is fun, dude.
-Right?
-I -- yeah, I still think it
would be more fun in person.
-Well, I'm sorry I couldn't be
there in person.
-Oh no, you really stepped in it
now, Seth.
-What?
-You know what? Alright?
Our beloved pet dog, Angus...
just went in for surgery.
-Okay.
-Not that you want to know
that because you didn't ask.
-It's not his fault, Maya.
He can't help
that he's a bad person.
-You know what?
[ Laughter ]
I'm really sorry to hear about
your dog, Maya.
What kind of surgery was it?
-Thank you.
Um, he's getting his
[bleep] enlarged.
[ Laughter ]
-See, Zoom is fun.
-We don't have a dog, you dope.
-You feel for it.
-You guys, I'm sorry, I have a
show to do, alright?
[ Laughter ]
Fred -- Fred, you're here.
Why would you join -- why would
you join via Zoom?
You're here.
-It just seemed
like a lot of fun.
-Yeah, Fred gets it.
-See, he's not stupid.
-Fred likes to have fun.
-Yeah, he's not a jerk.
-Fred, you just agreed with me
that it is better in person.
-Fred.
-Wow.
Is that true, Fred?
-Wow, Fred.
-Wow.
-Fred, don't lie to us.
-Yeah, Fred,
why would you lie to us?
Fred?
-[ Indistinct ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Indistinct talking ]
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, I gotta go.
Do you guys have any --
do you have anything
you want to tell us about,
Amy and Maya?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, "Baking It."
We're plugging "Baking It."
We hosted that together.
Watch that, you guys.
-It's great.
Watch it.
-Yeah. Please do.
And it's great
to see you both --
-"Baking It."
It's on Peacock.
Those are two of the best
people in the world.
Maya Rudolph and Amy Poehler
via Zoom, it doesn't matter.
-We love you very much.
-They're the best in the biz.
You can watch them on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with Chris Hayes.